[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] em
this is a real question
[Music]
being 100 serious
[Music]
hype bombers
on the homeland security committee I'm
just asking these questions
there's a couple different stories of
the homeland security I mean the FBI is
still looking for the bite bomber
still looking for the pipe bomber
but do we let pipe bombers on the on the
homeland security committee do we do
that
I don't know I have no idea everyone
keeps saying oh she's a 911 denier and
she believes in Jewish space lasers
um
just saying they're not related those
stories the pipe bomber story and
Marjorie Taylor green on the homeland
security committee obviously those
stories are not related and I'm not
trying to complete the do at all
oh maybe maybe I'm not uh Grandpa
Poopypants is freaking the [ __ ] out
over the documents case I don't again
folks look the media's got this [ __ ]
documents thing all wrong
all wrong
they they have completely lost why
Donald Trump isn't so much [ __ ]
trouble for the documents and Joe Biden
isn't
on true social he's posting about the
empty folders
that are missing the documents
he clearly understands
where he's in [ __ ] trouble you can
always bet and count on Donald Trump
projecting
always
you remember
I had
2016 2017 no corruption no collusion no
corruption no collusion no corruption or
no obstruction that's what it was excuse
me no obstruction no collusion no
obstruction no collusion no obstruction
no collusion
on and on and on that [ __ ]
chucklehead went
and of course there was collusion and
there's definitely there definitely was
obstruction
and the media is completely missing that
and this apple and orange comparison
of classified documents
and Joe Biden and the administration of
Joe Biden's team is playing this out
perfectly
perfectly
not saying a [ __ ] thing
let the media dig let them dig let them
be stupid
and what the political narrative on the
right die out on the limb with Donald
Trump
I'm gonna show you some of these uh
these true social posts that he's doing
apparently he's um also some news of
true social he's going to be abandoning
true social because he's talking to the
same [ __ ] group of nincompoops
and it's not helping
like it's not it's not working very well
my light was really bright and I don't
know what the hell's going on sorry
it's not working out very well so he's
trying to appeal to Facebook apparently
to let him back on Facebook so all you
folks out there on Facebook
and you know what what you should do
is go follow me on Facebook at meet Tony
Michaels the show Donald Trump but more
than anything find the link there to the
Tony michaels.com on Facebook if you're
on Facebook right now go to at the Tony
Michaels you can find the link to the
tonymichaels.com or just type that [ __ ]
in the Tony michaels.com
is you're going to want to go to the
YouTube channel for sure
we're trying to get the 20 000.
that's our goal two years of Tony 20
000. we're gonna do something special
now I've been asking
um our great moderators our our leads uh
MJ and Margie we've been discussing back
and forth now what we could do to
celebrate twenty thousand and what we
could give the audience that's a it's
important you guys are here every single
day you're dedicated you want to listen
to exactly what is going on and you want
to know exactly the narrative that you
have to carry with you in the world
that's why you come here
and it's a little bit of a cathartic
release from the stupid [ __ ] media
getting these stories absolutely wrong
yes
I'm attacking the media they're free to
say whatever they want and how they want
but boy are they failing the American
people in this story
his intent and his obstruction is the
key tenement here in this document's
case and he clearly knows he clearly
knows his intent has been found out with
these empty folders
I don't know what's happened in some of
these prosecutors uh meetings with his
attorneys and some of this communication
with the prosecutor especially since the
special counsel
and has been appointed with Jack Smith
the head of the special counsel
and what what Communications the Trump
teams had with them but obviously
obviously they want to [ __ ] know what
the hell was in those folders and where
the [ __ ] it's at
that's what they want to know
because he is he's posting about it you
can guaran damn T that [ __ ] crybaby
little [ __ ]
Grandpa poopy pants is gonna protect
project his fears
and his delusion all over any kind of
social media platform that'll let him
post it
and right now the only one that'll let
him post is his own and it's failing
badly
I would imagine that we see it more than
people over there who the [ __ ] is on
true social
the only the only reason why I have a
true Social account is so I can go over
and screenshot his stupid [ __ ]
that's it
that's it and I got the app downloaded
so he's probably tracking me oh
but he's freaking out freaking the [ __ ]
out at domestic Terror speaking of
domestic terrorists
we find out a little more information
about the Maga terrorist
out in New Mexico Pena
the failed Republican candidate
and we'll probably get into that more uh
into this hour when Gabe Sanchez joins
us I know he's been following this story
he's going to do a what was that on it
and also George Santos ho ho speaking of
George Santos
speaking of [ __ ] moglodytes
typical Republican lying frauds George
Santos apparently uh ran a GoFundMe
for a veteran and stole all the money
three thousand dollars worth oh man big
surprise
I mean what of course they ran he ran a
Griff and stole the money
of course he did
he's a Republican
I keep telling you people this he's not
an outlier
he just likes all the griffs all the
lies all the fraud he just wants to do
them all
he's a little greedy
a Republican
oh [ __ ] and of course they put him on
the small business committee are you
[ __ ] [ __ ] me
I guess you know
I guess that's you got to put him
somewhere right for the two years that
he's not going to resign I don't want
him to resign by the way
it's going to provide very good content
and very good cannon fodder for our
democracy over the next two years trust
me on this trust me on this I hope he
gets indicted on several charges and
still doesn't resign [ __ ] them stay
there yeah buddy
let's continue to talk about how much of
a fraud Republicans are because they're
going to defend him
they have to defend him that's part of
the deal that was his deal for his vote
for McCarthy
speaking of deals for votes
the headline of our show today Marjorie
Taylor green is on the homeland security
committee they let terrorists on the
homeland security what the [ __ ] are you
[ __ ] me
this is someone who was posting videos
before January 6 talking about how she
was playing with the president she was
planning with him to overturn the
[ __ ] election
overthrow our Constitution and you put
her in charge of Homeland Security what
the [ __ ]
tells wrong with you people oh yeah
you're Republicans
folks there this is not your daddy's
Republican party your grandpappy's
Republican party anymore
when they when they put the headline on
the Jumbotron
at CPAC in Texas and they said we are
all domestic terrorists they [ __ ]
meant it
they [ __ ] meant it
not a peep from these [ __ ] by
the way not a peep
about this gunman
and him paying 500 bucks can you believe
that that's part of the story I want to
ask Gabe Sanchez today because I know
he's dug into this
he only paid these guys 500.
what the [ __ ] 500 bucks
they're gonna go to prison for a long
time for 500 you might as well went and
Rob the goddamn gas station what the
[ __ ] is wrong with you
that's all he had was five no wonder
that [ __ ] no wonder that [ __ ]
moglodyte couldn't win I mean other than
he's crazy and he's an insurrectionist
Pena that's who I'm talking about
I'm sure Marjorie Taylor green is going
to defend him at some point
well I mean he had you know
evidence
that his election was stolen I'm sure
Carrie Lake would defend him today if if
she was asked about him
hmm
[Music]
I don't know yeah people are worried
about Marjorie Taylor green being on the
homeland security uh uh committee
because uh she she uh is a cue in honor
that's how she Rose to Congress
and she continued in Congress and she
was threatening and stalking and
doing weird [ __ ] with other members of
Congress
that's why she was kicked out of
committees and now now
the insurrectionist who wants to release
all
the January 6 insurrectionist
from prison because they're political
prisoners
you can't lock someone up to try to
overthrow the government how dare you
lock Republican moglodyte terrorist up
because they tried to overthrow the
government in an attempt to coup for the
Cheeto dust cue in honor how dare you
this is the person going to be on
homeland security committee listen
uh our friend Rock Dr Rachel bidagoffer
she was on yesterday and she's been
tweeting this morning
about these committees democrats should
use every single question every [ __ ]
question to direct back towards the
members of the committee
every [ __ ] one of them [ __ ] that [ __ ]
I mean they're not gonna get anything
done in these committees anyways these
committees are not designed to work for
the American people folks they're not
gonna be that's not gonna be the regular
order of the regular business
which it should be typical in Congress
but it's not going to be
they're not going to be trying to do
anything substantial or substantive for
the American people they're going to be
doing stupid [ __ ] political theater
so the Democrats and liberals in
Congress should participate
and they should form these questions now
they should start now asking these
[ __ ] questions every time they get a
microphone when they have time in the in
the hearing room you ask why in the [ __ ]
do we have someone who helped organize
the January 6th Insurrection on this
committee why
and start asking questions [ __ ] the
witnesses
[ __ ] the witnesses they ain't gonna have
to there ain't gonna be witnesses to be
questioned really they're not going to
call witnesses
to what Hunter Biden's laptop get the
[ __ ] out of here with this nonsense
so Democrats need to figure out now
right now right right [ __ ] now
that to do the job for the American
people is to expose and bring sunlight
to disinfect these manga terrorists in
our [ __ ] house
and in charge of our government
because they gerrymander the [ __ ] out of
our state districts which by the way we
should Democrats and liberals right now
right now should be trying every single
effort they can blue states red States
wherever we can to gerrymander the
districts back [ __ ] them [ __ ] them
gerrymander the [ __ ] out of it
yeah you goddamn right oh Tony you're
cheating you [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah you ain't
cheating you ain't trying [ __ ] them
you want your democracy you want to
fight for it you wanna you want it to be
here for the next Generation The
Generation after that you better start
fighting the fight that they're fighting
you better start
this [ __ ] Kumbaya [ __ ] and playing by
the rules [ __ ] that [ __ ] [ __ ] them this
this oh we gotta be we gotta be better
than them
there ain't gonna be an us
if you don't plan on fighting them where
the fight is at and I'm telling you the
reason why they have the reason why
Kevin McCarthy even dreamed that he
would be the Speaker of the House in the
first place and Marjorie Taylor green
would ever [ __ ] step foot on a
goddamn Homeland Security committee is
because they [ __ ] gerrymander
districts
that's what they did
they don't represent the majority
ideology in this country do you think
the majority of people want that [ __ ]
supposed pipe bomber possibly allegedly
I don't know
on the [ __ ] Homeland Security
committee someone who I mean you know
all the conspiracy theories and Q Anon
[ __ ] that she said she believed in the
past you know some people want to point
that out
but you want the person who participated
in the effort to overthrow our
government
think about it
think about it so you're gonna let
you're gonna let your [ __ ] precious
little little oh we gotta do it the
right way type [ __ ] we go we we have to
we have to stand up and and we have to
do democracy right and blah blah blah
blah yakety smack any [ __ ] [ __ ] them
gerrymander the [ __ ] out of it
and once we once we have the ability to
actually govern
in a decent [ __ ] way for the majority
ideology then change it
change it to where they can't
gerrymander District sure it's gonna
take a long time to get there
but if your goal is to stand back and
watch these [ __ ] terrorist these
self-proclaimed domestic terrorists take
over our governments take over our
homeland security committees
ramble on and on and on about dick pics
and laptops
Don Jr's posting a video about how uh
Joe Biden didn't charge Hunter Biden ran
or charged him ran I don't know what the
[ __ ] he's talking about he's talking
about how he laundered money and
pressing it on Hunter Biden
well we know that uh speaking of Don Jr
now we know from Michael Cohen
uh in a recent interview with Ben
mizellis on the Midas touch Network you
know we're affiliated with the mind to
touch Network we broadcast on their
Facebook page and we put videos up on
their YouTube channel
um that Michael Cohen was recently
interviewed I believe yesterday or day
before by Alan Bragg and the Manhattan
D.A
in a possible new chapter we watched the
um
the press conference with Alan Bragg
when the Donald Trump organization the
one that he ran he started his kids ran
were charged and convicted on 17 counts
of fraud
were sentenced by a judge to the maximum
which is not near enough a 1.61 million
dollars and Alan Bragg said in a press
conference into a microphone this we put
a into this chapter we move to the next
chapter and then they interview Michael
going
so maybe that's the next chapter maybe
the Stormy Daniels case
or other frauds
that Donald Trump and his family have
committed personally will come to light
in the Manhattan D.A who knows but I
think Donald Trump Jr is also projecting
what do you think
look folks
I know it feels like we should be
beating the [ __ ] out of these
chuckleheads
but they have an entire universe of
messaging
and narrative in this country
and there's armies
of these brain dead Trump humping
moglodytes out there that will believe
anything they're told
now the real fraud is that there's not
as many ASM as they say there are
they act like this this country is
divided in half [ __ ] that [ __ ] there
might be 12 of these [ __ ] Maga
zombies that'll believe anything Maga
says anything
oh yeah Trump trump definitely took
empty folders as as as cool items to
look at and to see get the [ __ ] out of
here you're telling me you're telling me
that some a manila folder with some
writing on it
is a cool item that you want to take as
significance from your presidency get
the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
he act like he kept all these folders
and then he packed them up get the [ __ ]
out of here
I believe that as much as I believe
Secret Service planted classified
documents in Joe Biden's house in his
office [ __ ] out of here that's all
[ __ ] we know exactly what happened
it's obvious what happened Joe Biden's
[ __ ] got packed inadvertently and was
stored in this place for [ __ ] six
years
until they were found by attorneys and
then turned over immediately to the FBI
doj and Nara Donald Trump stole the
documents
an attempt to cover up his coup
and then obstructed when they wanted
them back and possibly maybe just maybe
those empty folders that he's that he's
posting about I would imagine that maybe
some of that information worked its way
over to I don't know Saudi Arabia
huh
it really does seem kind of suspicious
that Jared Kushner received so much
[ __ ] money I wonder Don Jr
I wonder you [ __ ] scumbag
if
Jared Kushner has to pay rent
to Donald Trump somewhere in some
apartment under some name or some shell
company or something
I don't know two two billion dollars
seems like a lot of money not to launder
down through rent Don Jr I don't know
maybe he's giving away the game they
always do because they're always
projecting
always
every [ __ ] time never fails never
ever fails with these [ __ ] fascists
and these bone-headed nincompoop Nazis
holy [ __ ] and then they appoint them to
the the homeland security committee
there's also committee appointments for
Paul gozar
the the [ __ ] weirdo from Arizona his
own family says that guy needs to be
[ __ ] put in jail
he's crazy he's a goddamn terrorist his
family says dude you need to [ __ ]
chicken
you know the one that posted pictures on
his official Congressional account
showing AOC being killed and Joe Biden
being killed
that's just satire just just jokes funny
ha ha
that guy got put back on committees and
George Santos the fraud everyone wants
to talk about but again he just any old
Republican
yes Daniel Republican really honestly
typical [ __ ]
and he put him on the small business
committee
oh my God they can't stop with it with
the [ __ ] satire and parody of
themselves can they and you're gonna
want to see it I'm telling you your
sunlight is the best disinfectant you
gotta know what these [ __ ] are saying
you got to know what they're doing
and you gotta know how to make sure to
have the narrative and the national
messaging behind it to defeat these
[ __ ] idiots
that's right an election is far away but
it's gonna come soon and we have to
right now work hard to form our national
narrative and our national messaging and
this is the [ __ ] place right here the
Tony Michaels podcast you know I don't
hold back you know I make it raw I don't
give a [ __ ] not two not one no [ __ ] to
give here
we will say it just how we need to say
it so you are armed
with the proper narrative when you go
out there into the world rather it be
about uh pipe bombers being on the
homeland security committee rather be
Kevin McCarthy as a speaker and name
only
rather it be Donald Trump
obstructed and and his intent was to
cover up a coup on the documents
whatever it may be whatever it may be or
the manga terrorist out in New Mexico
that's not an oddball thing either and
George Santos shouldn't resign we should
hold all Republicans accountable to his
actions that he's going to take over the
next two years which will be despicable
and vile again not outside the realm of
typical Republicans so make sure you hit
that subscribe button here at the Tony
Michaels podcast on YouTube if you're on
another platform right now I'll ask you
this you're the best audience in the
world
but if you're on another platform right
now will you go over to YouTube just go
to the Tony michaels.com the links are
there the Tony michaels.com all the
links are there go follow us and
subscribe
on YouTube it is free then cost a
goddamn nickel not a penny
to come listen to this show every single
day Monday through Friday for two full
hours noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
so follow us on YouTube get us to twenty
thousand also follow us on all the
platforms all those links are there on
the Tony michaels.com you can go to
Twitter
you can you can download every single
episode on Apple Spotify Google whatever
your favorite directory is go download
it now download every single episode
subscribe there
follow us on Facebook at the Tony
Michaels and also follow us on Twitch at
the Tony Michaels if you're on Twitch
I'm also on Mastodon that Link's there
too
mastodon's kind of a new uh alternative
to Twitter I don't know how great it is
I don't know I post the the show over
there every day and if I have a good
tweet I'll go post it over there
so go follow me on Mastodon follow me on
all the things all of them all of them
and that's a great way to show support
but here's my ask
until we get to 20 000 what I need you
to do is not just subscribe to the
YouTube channel but share share this
link Today's show tomorrow show the next
show
it with three friends find three friends
if they don't like it find three more
friends that's all I ask just three just
three shares three likes three
subscribes and we'll get to twenty
thousand fast if we can do that if we
get half the audience because we're at
like I don't know just under fourteen
thousand I think is what we're at now we
just get half of them and half of those
get three people to subscribe holy [ __ ]
we'll be way over 20. way over to well
oh we'll bust through that 20 000
subscriber ceiling fast think about it
think about it just a little little help
that I need from you the audience
because you're the greatest audience in
the world and we have the greatest
moderators in the world on the live
YouTube jet
so make sure you help us out this month
get the 20 000. everybody stick around
we're going to talk about this uh
Marjorie Taylor green but I also want to
get into her buddy Pena
out in New Mexico so don't go anywhere
we'll be right back right after these
messages
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
so these members of Congress
Dominique pardons for trying to be
committed January 6th
[Music]
they get many assignments instead what
the [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] man
I don't know I guess I guess in this
country now we're okay with uh pint
bombers being on the homeland security
committee I'm not saying it has anything
to do with the story about margins
tether green I'm not connecting those
two things at all
at all at all I'm not trying to connect
those two things
not at all
oh my God
oh
what the [ __ ] is happening I I also want
to show you today if we get to it um a
video of it's going around uh Kirsten
Cinema and Joe manchin high-fiving and I
want to tell you how [ __ ] uneventful
and
who gives a [ __ ] and this is
who gives a [ __ ] Joe manchin and Kirsten
Cinema
are basically by all means at this point
deemed irrelevant irrelevant
they're gonna help Chuck Schumer get
these judges because that's quiet but
they're not going to get a bill
they're not going to get a bill if if
the if the Republicans in the house
actually raised the debt ceiling they're
gonna vote for that
the only the only thing I could see that
Joe manchin and Kirsten Cinema and a
block on here is in September to keep
the government open but they're not
going to do that the Kirsten Cinema is
not going to go there either she don't
want to be blamed
now she literally is going to um run as
an independent
in Arizona for her senate seat
um likely against Kerry Lake now
the crazy [ __ ] election fraud lady
and uh possibly
a Democrat
[Music]
um
let's hope that we get a Democratic
candidate she's The Independent in Kerry
Lake the crazy election denier
she's not going to have an easy time at
that election so
Kirsten Cinema and Joe manchin
high-fiving over the filibuster
is [ __ ] laughable
but it's going around people are sharing
it people are talking about it so that's
what we do here is to make sure you
understand how [ __ ] stupid this is
and how ill relevant that video is
I'm gonna show it to you because you
know we got to give sunlight to
disinfect this stuff and to disinfect
the idea that somehow they're going to
be relevant
look Joe manchin is going to be the
Democrat of West Virginia
you're not going to change that in 2024
there's plenty of other areas for us to
concentrate our efforts on like the
cinema race in Arizona but several other
races now here in Missouri Josh Hawley
is going to be running against Lucas
Koontz I don't know if you saw that
video I don't think we played that maybe
we should play that today
Lucas Koontz uh ran against uh Bush the
the heir to the Bush beer
um Anheuser-Busch um fortune and Trudy
Bush Valentine as she won in the primary
against Lucas Koontz Lucas Koontz did
really well in the rural areas in the
Trump trump country as it were here in
Missouri in the primary the Democratic
primary you have to remember that
but he did really well
he had high showings there was high
turnout for him in those early areas he
couldn't overcome the vote against uh a
valentine Bush but
the point is is that he may head to head
against Holly
if he can secure the Democratic
nomination
um he just he just may just may be able
to flip that seat
he actually has the pedigree that Holly
claims or that Holly wants he lives in
Missouri he's actually lives here he
doesn't live in Virginia like Josh
Hawley at [ __ ] fraud
did you know Josh Hawley had to rent a
house in Jefferson City Missouri which
is the capital of Missouri when he
became the Attorney General because he
didn't have a house he didn't live in
Missouri
you had to rent a house to become the
Attorney General
he's a phony
he's a fraud that's right he's a
Republican
George Santos is not is not a rarity
folks
he's not
he just not very good at it right he's
stupid
and a lot of Republicans are stupid
but he's stupid a lot
I mean that's the only thing that really
separates him again most Republicans
pick out three or four lines you get
these [ __ ] boxes like Marjorie Taylor
green bobert gozar Andy Biggs Matt Getz
they get up to 10 or 15 lines that
they're telling at a time George Santos
wants all of them he's like oh I like
that lie oh I like I like all the lies
I'll just tell all of them and I'll do
all the frauds I'll do all the frauds
I'll do all the griffs I'll do
everything I'll do all the Republican
[ __ ] all at once that's where we
went wrong and again you're a [ __ ]
idiot
you're a [ __ ] idiot
I mean here's the thing
we watched in Georgia
a Senate candidate Herschel Walker
who we know about his public life
because he wrote it in a [ __ ] book
his craziness about guns and threatening
to kill people and putting guns to
people's temples and threatened to kill
himself and Russian Roulette all kinds
of crazy ass [ __ ] he's got multiple
personality all kinds of weird-ass crazy
[ __ ] this guy stood on stage
stood on stage after Senator Reverend
Warnock in a debate said this guy
pretends to be a police officer
and to own the lib Warnock Herschel
Walker goes you goddamn right hold my
beer and he pulls out a fake badge
claiming it's real he pulls out of fake
badge claiming it's real and needs some
kind of [ __ ]
peace officer on law enforcement
official
he has no Authority and that badge gives
him none but he whips it out
and everyone's worried about Santos are
you [ __ ] me
I wonder what I wonder how many fake
badges Santo says you know what I mean
I'm just saying
I bet he's got some fake law enforce he
probably even has in his car he probably
even has one of those lights that you
plug into the the cigarette lighter
you know what I mean and puts it on top
so he looks like a police officer you
know I'm talking about the Cherry right
I bet he has one of those somewhere
next to his fake badge
100 percent
Hondo persento he probably even has a
fake gun that he spray painted the
orange dip of
like a holster
you know like uh one you know one
underneath your arm make you look tough
I mean you know he's got to pretend to
be tough
what what would a republican be without
pretending to be tough Jesus Christ
these [ __ ] gays
and we're worried we're worried about
all these about George Santos being
being a being a fraud and a phony what
the face just look he's just a
republican that's it he's just a
Republican and so that's all he is he's
just a [ __ ] Republican
just a republican Hell Boy okay let's um
let's message Gabe Sanchez see where
he's at this morning we're gonna go to
the shitless Roundup uh here really soon
we're gonna round up all the Tweety
tweets and Trinity Trends you know
that's what we do here on the Tony
Michaels podcast I'm telling you this
this new Twitter it gives [ __ ] list a
whole new name didn't it
oh my God
I can't find [ __ ] on there anymore
the trending topics are [ __ ] Elon is
totally [ __ ] destroyed Twitter
destroyed it absolutely destroyed it my
timeline's all [ __ ] up I got Benny
Johnson in this [ __ ] this [ __ ]
beta uh Nick Adams you seen this guy
who who only wants dicks on his M M's he
only wants M M's to have dicks in his
mouth that's it and until Eminem makes
only M M's with dicks he's not gonna
have any but he likes Hooters apparently
he loves
loves Hooters
loves it never post a picture other than
the food and Hooters but he loves
Hooters he loves some him some hooters
apparently Hooters Hooters Hooters
Hooters he hates M M's that don't have
dicks that's what he's posting about
that's what's in my [ __ ] feed I don't
know what to tell you Elon has done this
to us
can't find [ __ ] get my [ __ ] on there
can't keep up with anything so you gotta
go here's what you gotta do and I've
started to do this on Twitter and before
we get to the [ __ ] list I'm going to
give you an idea and and a lot of people
aren't on Twitter but if you are take a
listen and if you're not yeah [ __ ]
sit there and listen to we'll get we'll
get to the videos here soon
um what you got to do is you got to go
find some accounts and put them on
notifications that's the most important
thing and take accounts that aren't
[ __ ] giving you
what you need to know off your
notifications take them off
I understand you might like the account
it might be funny or whatever take that
[ __ ] off I started to scrub my
notifications and and that's the tab
that you're gonna have to use for a
while to go look through and develop
your own little timeline because elon's
not going to do it for you and and and
you can watch the show here and see some
of the accounts that you should follow
um we we show them all the time
here on the you should definitely put me
on notifications and Gabe Sanchez on
notifications Midas Touch on
notification Punchbowl news is another
one that's Scott McFarlane uh Kyle
Chaney is another good one
um so
be be putting those folks on your
timeline uh Ron philipkowski he's a
great one for Clips uh acen Aaron rupar
those are great ones for clips that you
need to see and and make sure that
you're you're paying attention without
having to watch hours and hours and
hours of Trader TV News Network they do
a great service uh by by posting some of
those clips so those are some of the
accounts that you want to put on
notifications so you're watching your
notifications because the timeline and
really the lobby you know the little
house icon that you go to and it's kind
of you know the the lobby as I call it
like where everyone's hanging out right
that's [ __ ] now total [ __ ] Elon has
destroyed it he's making sure that right
Wingers and these anti-backs [ __ ]
have have all the algorithm in the in
the lobby not people who are actually
presenting facts and Truth
even the people who want to find it so
you're gonna have to seek it out on
Twitter now you're it's not going to be
automatically delivered up to you
through the algorithm they're just not
doing it like that anymore because
they're trying to push their propaganda
they know they've lost they know they're
gonna lose they know that this
pro-democracy Coalition has has banded
against their [ __ ] in-cell right-wing
thinking they're against their white
privilege and and they're scared so
that's why they've moved to try to have
more right-wing [ __ ] on Twitter in the
timeline so you can still use the
platform though again there's still ways
to manipulate it so you have a decent
timeline so you're keeping up with these
things one way to do that one way to do
that is to come here to the Tony
Michaels podcast every single weekday
for two full hours we will try to keep
you up in the stories like yesterday we
had this Pena story it wasn't headline
news hardly anywhere but we covered it
Gabe Sanchez gave you a great breakdown
he's probably going to give us some new
news today I know um there's news about
the amount that Pena played paid these
four other guys
um and then also about when he was
trying to encourage them to shoot at
these houses
um because it's not just about
intimidation it looked like looked like
it was attempted murder
it seems like it seems like it to me if
these reports are true so we're gonna
get Gabe Sanchez to see if he can give
us some new news on the Pena case he's
supposed to appear in a federal
courthouse I believe today and maybe
we'll get some news from that as well
and so hang tight here because we're
going to go through the Tweety tweets
and trendy Trends right now the [ __ ]
list Roundup starts the countdown
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Trends in the [ __ ] list Roundup oh boy
let's see what we got first here and of
course and I want to show our thumbnail
here for today because this is this is
the St this should be one of the top
stories of today uh paired with the Pena
story
um it's very important
this Pena guy this guy ran and lost by
like 40 [ __ ] percent margin or some
stupid [ __ ] by like 3 500 votes
in a state house rate not even close not
even close to winning
he really wasn't even a competitor in
the race
when you consider the margin
but this [ __ ] fool was at the January
6th Insurrection that Marjorie Taylor
green helped plan with the Cheeto dust
cue in honor she made a video about it
we might show it today
and then down at CPAC I know this seems
oh this is all trivial you're full of
[ __ ] bull [ __ ] Matt schlapp the guy
who's groping people and molesting
people uh in campaigns Herschel Walkers
to be specific he's a closeted Predator
molester
they posted on the CPAC Jumbotron Gabe
Sanchez we are all domestic terrorists
and then this [ __ ] this [ __ ] slug
is now on the homeland security what the
[ __ ] are you [ __ ] me listen listen I
didn't know Gabe Sanchez that in this
country we put pipe bombers on the
homeland security committee I didn't
know I mean I'm not saying the stories
are related I'm not saying it's the same
way that it's like if you want to catch
a criminal you've got to work with a
Criminal you gotta oh is that it
criminal you know I think that's the
same thing that the Republicans are
thinking right now if you want to catch
a terrorist you've got to become put
them on there put them on the security
committee right exactly oh my god well
you know it really
this you did a great job on this
thumbnail today that's why I wanted to
show it and and there and the reason why
is because
just the fact
of her yelling and screaming here in
this in this little
um thumbnail and then the we are all
domestic terrorists with this [ __ ]
story about Pena because I know there's
new news and I know you've probably been
tracking it because you're doing it what
was that the one thing that um the the
two bits of news is the amount of money
that he paid these guys and that they
split which I'm yeah what the [ __ ] and
then and then he the thing that he was
doing to encourage him to change the
time that he was shooting at these
people's residents is [ __ ] crazy
because I think that's going to bring
other charges and and I don't know if we
have news of charges I know he was
supposed to go before a judge this
morning so I don't know if he's no no no
so he's he's going before a judge uh uh
what it New Mexico is what one hour
ahead that's mountain time or is it is a
question I I I don't I'm
um I don't know
yeah they're an hour ahead of me
um here's what's happening he is going
before a judge at uh like 1 or 1 30
mountain time so which would be 12 my
time so it'll be after the show he goes
up now okay he's probably but he's
supposed to be in front of a judge today
though right yeah yeah his pre-trial
arraignment is going to happen today now
I don't think anything news gonna really
come out of it we pretty much know what
happened right we have about 50 charges
charged because they can't charge him
with uh like is this this is a United
States courthouse too right is it a
federal courthouse or is it uh us it's
just a U.S or not not a federal uh that
I know of uh because when I look up in
the New Mexico Von Von Hilliard was in
front of the courthouse this morning
um if we go
um I know I was listening to some
reports that Von Hilliard was making
this morning in front of the in front of
the courthouse but um here here's my
question is if they have formal charges
because there is no and
what I want to point out here
is that there's one thing that
Republicans know when they did this
um when they put this up at CPAC right
now again we could go through the whole
story with Matt schlapp and CPAC that's
a whole nother [ __ ] ball of wax even
in an outlying story in this thumbnail
yeah and there's a lot of stuff packed
into this thumbnail today
um that's why I bring it up and he did
such a great job of capturing it
um but the the thing is
when they said we are all domestic
terrorists there are no there are no
federal charges that exist to charge a
domestic terrorist there's terrorism
charges but no domestic terrorism charge
we don't have those statutes uh we've
never really had that because most of
the time racist white people were making
the laws and they were the ones who were
the terrorists hmm seems kind of funny
here that we have these white people in
Congress taking over I don't know
Homeland Security committees these white
Christian nationalists these America
First Nazis
declaring themselves domestic terrorists
and we have no federal domestic
terrorist charges that's why they're
that's that is why it's possible that
Pena will not
um actually seed
um a time in a federal courthouse but a
state house
um so what are these charges do you have
them there of what he's been charged
with yes so what I what I have is uh
we've got
uh he's currently being charged with
four counts each of shooting at a
dwelling shooting at or from a motor
vehicle and conspiracy to commit a
shooting at a dwelling and one count
each of possession of a firearm by a
felon attempt to commit aggregate
aggravated assault with a deadly weapon
and criminal solicitation to commit a
shooting at a dwelling now now there's
something to keep in mind here there's
like it's like 15 or 16 counts or
something like that right more than a
dozen counts I think is what what the
what the total is and we'll find out
more today now I don't think much will
change right now now however
you brought up something earlier which
was this idea that he told now he paid
Three Brothers three Trujillo Brothers
okay there were four people involved in
the shooting one of the four is the
confidential witness that has flipped on
off well on the other four of them right
true he the three true he's the one
that's in trouble for drug trafficking
no no no no no no not that we know of no
okay so this is this is a different
there's a difference so this is as it
developed yesterday we found out that
there were three Trujillo brothers that
were paid 500 in cash to split which oh
my God holy [ __ ] man they did all that
because there are six shootings in total
now they're not sure exactly of all
these shootings are there specifically
yeah six shootings four definitely them
right two still up so but for sure they
got paid 500 bucks between the three of
them to go shoot at buildings and houses
and they had to split it yeah yeah holy
[ __ ] no wonder he failed this [ __ ]
game
payment for a hit job I mean I mean it's
ridiculous if you think about like let's
say just like five shootings right so
it's 500 bucks it's a hundred dollars
per shooting there's four additional
there's four people that he hired so
it's 25 bucks that wouldn't even cover
the gas man or the ammunition no not at
all and that's the thing and so so what
happened was so he got caught so they
went to representative state
representative Linda Lopez's house right
and he actually had an this is his
opponent yeah well no no no no no no no
no no Garcia was not was not was not a
Target
um Miguel Garcia tried to get him uh
disqualified
from the race but the but the judge was
like well
I mean he has the right to vote so maybe
the judge was thinking here maybe the
judge was thinking since in New Mexico a
felon does can regain their right to
vote which right and he did in April 20.
begrudge the system if you can vote you
should be able to be part of the system
but also I'm sure the judge is like
there's no way he's going to win in this
District there's no way I don't know I
mean like there was no there was no I
mean yes yeah for sure right because if
you remember 75 of the time it has gone
for Democrats only 16 of the population
of registered voters in that uh in that
District are Republicans so you're not
going to occupy like a 48 yeah a point
margin or something yeah it would be 76
to 24. yeah it was crazy it wasn't
anywhere near it was never going to win
it was never [ __ ] rigged it was never
put against him no one was if you think
Donald Trump lost by a lot by eight
million votes is this guy I mean not
even he's a he's he makes Donald Trump
look like a winner and that is difficult
like that
and you also have to remember that this
is a small District right the
Republicans aren't going to throw money
at this because they look at and they go
oh there's no way we would win right why
would we waste money on this race now
they did know they did know about Pena's
pass right 19 convictions for various
crimes all connected to this Smash and
grab scheme where they literally they
they
they steal a car and they [ __ ] Ram it
into the business and then they go and
they said this is where his previous
felonies come right and this is where he
he served seven years in prison from
from May 2000 or may 2009 to March 2016.
so it's it's been a while since he he
got out of prison and he served prison
diamond yeah and then he was unveil or
he was under uh uh he was under
do for five years he was put under
um
uh why am I playing this uh basically
under like monitor right they had them
on over the next five years unlike
unlike probation oh okay okay so he was
he was he was uh he was had to report to
a pro po or probation officer right look
I don't want the audience to get
confused felons can be reformed there's
a lot of people that have non-violent
crimes this is not a nine violent crime
by the way but uh there's there's there
and there can be felons that are
reformed out there and they should be
and they should be welcomed back into
society when they do reform this guy
obviously is not when he's hiring people
for 500 bucks to go shoot up a house but
the thing that the thing that is most
significant news that we that we and I
know you want to talk about it yeah yeah
is the time talk about this is the
craziest thing of the whole story so far
I'm like what the [ __ ] this guy just
wasn't trying to intimidate by shooting
bullets at a certain time of night he
was encouraging these other four to do
it at a certain time and why why was he
so yeah so what happened was these
shootings happened and they happened
late at night and a lot of these
accounts where people like the daughter
of Representative state representative
Linda Lopez her daughter woke up and
thought there was a spider on her face
turns out it was debris from the ceiling
yeah because you would get tickled by
this day exactly right and then when
they woke up they realized oh [ __ ] and
then there's like you know yeah didn't
they think there was sand in the bed and
[ __ ] yeah it would be really confusing
at night and yeah and you've got former
County Commissioner Debbie O'Malley who
he went to go visit her one of the
people
rang her doorbell it's a video doorbell
there's footage of it exactly and so
what happened was they were shooting
uh he was okay so Solomon Pena was
pissed off
that not only did they shoot too high
but they also shot two late at night
and the reason he was mad was because he
wanted the people inside those homes to
be shot so he wanted them to say he said
hey look you gotta aim not why they're
laying yeah it would be because I mean
if you think about the logistics of like
and I don't know what the street looks
like but typically when when when
neighborhoods are being designed this is
just engineering 101 yeah typically the
houses set higher than the road because
the road is used a lot of time for
drainage yeah there's a ditch or a curb
where where it's draining uh sometimes
the gutters actually go out into the
road into the curb so that so elevation
wise the road sits lower in most times
or the front yard sits lower not all the
time but that's typically how how Urban
engineering is done when they're
engineering a a subdivision right so
um it's just construction background for
me and like concrete I used to do but
anyways the point is is that uh you
would naturally shooting towards the
house if you were in the front yard or
at the road or in a car you would be
shooting from a down position to the
house it naturally anyways but so it
would be very hard
to to
um hurt someone in this way when they're
laying in bed so he wanted them to be up
and at him but I think yeah he wanted he
wanted them to go around 8 PM when he
knew that people would most likely be up
right they'd still be wandering around
but but here's the thing when I thought
about this this morning because that
thought entered my mind about you know
and again I know it sounds complicated
the engineering but obviously the road
grade is a lot lower in elevation than
where the house sits
um because I don't know how it is in New
Mexico because obviously like New Mexico
is like well there's different yeah
there are different constructions in
different places in the country but but
they they would grade the road to be
lower anyways the point is this
I actually believe because if we go back
and you look at the initial reports of
this happening
when it happened they had no idea that
someone shot guns into the house until
the very next morning when the lights
were on right and you could see the
holes in the drywall because they were
trying to figure out what the [ __ ] why
was there sand and a spider in the bed
or whatever it was and they're like holy
[ __ ] it's [ __ ] gunshots so my guess
is my get and I'm just if we look at the
timing and all this my guess is this is
that the reports came out the next
morning that they didn't even know that
they were being shot at during the night
and that pissed him off more than
anything he's like look I want people to
be awake I wanted to be up and I wanted
to be possibly being hit so that they
know we're shooting guns at him because
the the fact that you would have gunfire
in your house and then wake up next
morning realize it would be less
intimidating than like it happening like
in a movie you know what I mean like
like a [ __ ] movie the windows
breaking and yeah yeah you know right
yeah you know what I'm talking about
yeah well yeah it's like that's probably
what penny is doing he's like look I saw
it under a movie and you gotta do it
this way you know what I mean he's like
you got to go below the window you know
but but the thing that uh that I think
is is another important detail here is
so up until this point so there are four
guys right four guys he hired and one of
them who has flipped on everyone else uh
he's the non-brother yeah he's the
non-brother the creature hero brothers
and one non-brother and he's the one who
has all the information he's got the
text messages the Google Map well they
got Google Maps whoa they weren't text
messaging this [ __ ] yeah so they text
message the direct address the exact
address of those homes Christ payment so
that's how they know there's four for
sure yeah well also because the guy was
in the car with them on each of the
shootings that happened oh God damn and
then and then here's the here's the
thing that's crazy and also incredibly
lucky on on the on the fact of uh of
state representative Linda Lopez and her
daughter no one was injured in these
shootings no yeah no one no I mean like
these guys have super like they have a
stormtrooper aim okay these guys cannot
hit a [ __ ] just well and it sounds
like it was a little bit intentional
because he was pissed off that they
weren't aiming for somebody they were
just aiming to intimidate more than
anything I'm gonna go with the fact that
these idiot extremists have shitty aim
and they weren't able to do it but what
we did what we did like Dan Crenshaw
yeah exactly and Stuart Rhodes
saying I don't know I passed McCain it's
fine okay but the thing that's really
important here
is that uh the last of the shootings
where he was he was like oh this is you
know you guys aren't doing this right
whatever whatever
he showed up he was there for the
shooting at state representative Linda
Lopez's house he had an AR with him in
the car but it jammed
and he couldn't shoot it right
who oh this is this is Solomon Pena
has been so he's been so pissed off he
shows up to the last one and says okay
I'm gonna actually help out with this
okay I'm gonna actually do this
rifle yes he put He he bought his AR
from I don't know where uh either it was
it was Human air or it was a gun air or
something but he but to Reports say that
it jammed he couldn't shoot and then
someone else in the car shot with the
Glock then 40 minutes later or so in
less than five miles away from exactly
where they were shooting
uh Jose Trujillo gets pulled over right
and they pulled him over on an expired
registration but then we find out that
the car was actually registered just to
sell them on Pena so they started
looking through the car oh I find out
there's a Glock in the car there's when
is this is this what is this what gave
them the um this is what got them in
because that is
why Trujillo is charged with drug
trafficking and possession of firearms
so not only did did Pena
only pay them 500 bucks which look I'm
not promoting anyone paying anyone to do
this type of stuff but if you're gonna
do it God damn buy more than a candy bar
for [ __ ] sake and what are you doing
There's jobs out there that are paying
that are paying damn near 25 an hour
what do you anyways the point is this
the point is this not only did he not
pay them worth a [ __ ]
he [ __ ] gave him a car that that was
not registered properly in his name and
not only that to drive around oh my God
only that Tony but inside the car
Trujillo had eight more than 800 pills
of what they believed to be fentanyl a
large amount of cash a Glock with a drum
magazine no wait a second wait a second
he's a republican Gabe Sanchez he's a
Republican and he's against fentanyl I
know it for sure and he's probably he's
probably one of these they're putting
fentanyl on Halloween candy
[ __ ] right so I guess maybe he
would know I guess he would know so yeah
eight more than 800 pills of what they
believe to be fentanyl a large amount of
cash a Glock with a drum magazine and an
AR which I'm assuming is the same AR
that uh pictures of this do we have the
police pictures I bet I bet I bet manga
is really pissed off that they took
pictures of the evidence so they're
probably really mad that they took
pictures of the evidence I mean let me
fight because there are great domestic
areas Pena
I've had a difficult time trying to find
this criminal complaint like the news
organizations have it and I don't know
if it's just been shared with them like
in just like within the Inner Circle but
I haven't everyone is referencing this
criminal complaint and I cannot find it
and I'm sure you find it like in public
record yeah like I'm trying to find it
in in like um maybe maybe what we should
do is connect with um some of the
reporters for the Albuquerque news they
might be able to get us a copy of it so
we can show it on the show but yeah
there is uh as we're following the story
because folks I know this sounds trivial
but this is a really important story and
the reason why is because they literally
branded themselves domestic terrorists
right they did this guy was at the
Insurrection on January 6th
he's trying to take over parts of our
government as
some [ __ ] box like Marjorie Taylor green
who helped organize the January 6th
Insurrection there's a video of her
walking down the steps and she's like oh
I just got out of a meeting with the
great Jesus the mango Mussolini Jesus
and we're planning we're planning to
overthrow the government and overthrow
the Constitution make sure Joe Biden
never gets in office I mean she
literally said that [ __ ] and then they
branded themselves as domestic
terrorists this [ __ ] story matters
yeah it matters and it matters in the
National narrative and and making sure
that we pin up every one of these
[ __ ] who are responsible for
stoking this type of violence and this
type of political rhetoric in this type
of political violence and this domestic
terrorism it is important that we tie it
to him because it is their fault
if you don't believe that that match lap
and CPAC and the Republican party and
the America First Nazi party
is partly responsible for what happened
in New Mexico with this pinion lunatic I
got evidence right here on the thumbnail
that Gabe Sanchez made for today's show
we are all domestic terrorists
what in the [ __ ] this is important [ __ ]
and as we follow this story and we'll
bring you more what's the link you have
for me here so that is one image that I
was able to uh find that they were
sharing now there's there's some other
images that were text messages there's
one with uh Salomon Pena and
um so this is from this is from the
traffic stop that they this is yeah this
is from the traffic stop and this is uh
this is what was included in the
criminal complaint but um like I said uh
no News public like no news outlet has
actually shared this publicly that
people can actually look for so I'm
assuming I'm sure maga's super pissed
that yeah that they took photos of a
republican politician's evidence how
dare they do they I mean they didn't
take pictures of Joe Biden's evidence
and they didn't take pictures of Hunter
Biden's criminal evidence of his dick
pics I mean hunter Biden took him
himself and they tried to put him on
social media
this is really stupid stuff but this is
I mean why why why why do we even have
to go here the reason why is because
they put people like Paul goes are on
the oversight committee they put people
like Scott Perry who's had his cell
phone seized by the feds because of his
plot in the state elector scheme to
overturn our constitution
and he's on the [ __ ] oversight
committee are you [ __ ] [ __ ] me
and then Marjorie Taylor green
is on the homeland security you don't
think George Santos story yeah is on the
uh airspace a small fraud the small
fraud committee well he's on the one
that overlooks the PPP loans which of
course why again why uh why would you
put the people that did it oh their
logic is like well hey look these people
clearly know these things like the back
of their hand because they're the ones
that are committing the crime so why
wouldn't we be assigning them these
these these uh committees right makes
total sense Kevin McCarthy Kevin
McCarthy who barely won his seat through
15 rounds 14 rounds of failing and one
final round of you mean the guy who's
barely speaker is that what you're
saying yeah the guy who's barely speaker
right the guy who doesn't have a spine
whose speaker and name only who's got a
gavel and a sign above his door but it
doesn't mean [ __ ] the guy that says oh
look trust me and I will go after those
woke indoctrinating schools and I'll
make sure that this and this and that
and that and blah blah [ __ ] and then
try to go after Eric swalwell and the
FBI is like yeah Eric swallow he totally
uh totally cooperated he actually unders
covered the whole scheme by making sure
that he gave us the proper information
at the proper time just like I don't
know most reasonable people will
cooperate at a reasonable time with
authorities speaking of George Santos
and Republican frauds again he's just a
normal Republican fraud I thought this
is a great clip from uh Patriot takes
that he found I don't know this is when
this is from this is kind of [ __ ]
white nationalist loud majority they had
another one where he was um
they interviewed him at like a
conference or something they had another
video with this too I haven't seen this
one this is new and then this is what
he's talking about here is how much he
gets paid in Congress
um this is hilarious oh this is a new
one yeah watch this watch oh wow is
there something you you can count on me
one thing money ain't moving me because
it's not this job that's it's not the
salary I'm in for I guess to do that no
I can guarantee if there was ever a pay
cut in history that somebody took it's
definitely me because Congress let me
tell you something it gave Santa
Congress is not as lucrative as fleecing
veterans in a GoFundMe it's definitely
not as lucrative as committing fraud and
policing veterans
um about their service dog yeah I don't
know if you've you have this story three
thousand dollars yes well that's the one
we know of so far so basically so
basically
he's kind of like Lara Trump right like
he's not stealing money again I say it
all the time and I'm always right right
I'm like he likes all the frauds he
likes all the griffs and he's just like
I like that one I like that one oh
you're gonna have a you're gonna have a
dog charity that you're gonna steal from
I want to do that too like how does this
guy I've had the idea the idea that
Santa's like it's not the salary that's
keeping me here dude I can tell you
exactly why he's there one the benefits
are phenomenal if you're a if you're a
representative uh but also the fact that
you're now
you now have Insight you now have inside
information and knowledge about certain
things that I don't know maybe other
people would find in for uh helpful and
uh beneficial and that you would want to
sell to certain people uh the idea that
this also connects him with lobbyists
who's like well this guy clearly is
already [ __ ] corrupt so we can easily
buy him off for whatever policy we want
to push forward so it doesn't it it
makes total sense that when he's like oh
it's not the salary that's Cape mayor
yeah it's the connections you're about
to make through lobbyists the benefits
you receive as a representative and the
idea that you're like oh if anyone ever
took a pay cut in history yeah a lot of
that money came from [ __ ] foreign
people foreign entities people that were
smuggling Chinese people threw a yacht
into the U.S like George Santos only the
best people he surrounds himself with
yeah I mean he is the best people right
I mean he's a really good Republican
he's good at this Republican stuff he's
good at it he's perfect at projecting
and lying like this [ __ ] cokehead
have you seen this new video from Don Jr
no my answer no I saw like five seconds
of it but I haven't watched the whole
thing he's totally he's totally [ __ ]
projected is this about Hunter right
well of course it is yeah yeah of course
it's about his jealousy that Hunter's
dad loves him yeah of course God his
dick is so much bigger than mine his dad
loves him oh God I can't wait I can't
wait I can't wait for the video
eventually because you know he's gonna
say it yeah you know Don Jesus
sausages sausage oh my God how many
people are saying yeah maybe that's why
he's upset is like Kimberly Guilfoyle
saw the images originally and was like
oh my god well my God oh my God
and then Don Jr was like what are you
what are you talking about what are you
talking about and then she's like oh no
nothing and he's like no pull that image
back up maybe that's maybe Gabe Sanchez
I think we're on to something maybe this
is how this Hunter by laptop story came
to light Kimberly gilvore received
copies of the huge sausage that is
Hunter Biden's she's looking at him and
it just [ __ ] flung out of control and
then out of control uh can you can you
airdrop that to me
I I I I just wanted his evidence I just
wanted to say and he's like I gotta go
to the bathroom real quick
I gotta I gotta take a [ __ ] on my and
then and then he sends it to a bunch of
his friends he's like hey dudes check
this out huh and they're like dude what
the [ __ ] is wrong with you a master lap
on the text he goes oh I like that you
know what I bet I bet Don Jr I bet I
would put money on it that this guy
tried to float pics of Hunter Biden's
huge hog as his own
oh yeah maybe that's why him and Matt
Slap are such good friends too I know
probably it could be I mean it's the I
look they are obsessed with other
people's genitalia they are obsessed
with grabbing other people's jobs they
loved they love to control and grope and
fondle and project those things onto uh
the drag community and lgbtq right he's
saying like oh you guys are groomers you
guys are molesting you guys are taking
advantage of dude you guys are the ones
that literally have not stopped talking
about another dude's dick
for years oh my God they want to have
congressional committees to smoke out
how big this guy's dick is they're like
I've got the contents of every [ __ ]
dick pic on this thing I'm driving like
I got it smoking crack with hot hookers
with his dick out like what I mean what
what why do you guys have that why do
you have it so easily accessible in your
jacket pocket you're just gonna put it
you're just gonna they're like put it in
the computer oh it's so rude to it
they're into it uh well I want to point
something out here he's not in his
normal setting here right so he doesn't
because normally he said yes with the
bookshelves and it's got the it's got
the glass type dildo yeah the whatever
the hell that bong uh dildo is and then
the the American flag that his family
should have from his family no one
served in the military I don't know who
he bought that from right I don't know
what food market he got it from a flea
market or like one of those military
storage shops you know but he's not his
natural setting here so this is right
off and it's he's not his New York
office because sometimes he does it in
his in his his truck tower office him
and Eric uh they like to feel important
so they go to their office and uh
they're like oh look at me tap it tap it
tappy
do they do the typey typey thing yeah I
think they go typy typy typy and the
computer's off you know oh okay so just
just to get the sound of the keyboard is
that it yeah I think they say it like
there's no actual but they like them to
say
yeah it pretty much is because okay that
makes they don't they don't even have
here look let's just say that no one at
the Trump organization trusts those two
enough to give them an actual computer
or at least a computer that has an
internet connection right because
they're like oh look what are you guys
doing they're like I'm picking out the
problems and they're just like playing
Solitaire I'm trying to find more Hunter
Biden dick pics right I mean well here's
the other thing too I don't know if the
audience knows this or not but we
actually had Eric Trump on the show yeah
um that was a thing that was almost a
year ago I think yeah he was crying like
a little we should maybe get him back on
the show if every if anyone wants to go
watch the interview of Eric Trump on the
show just go to the Tony Michaels
podcast on YouTube subscribe first don't
forget to subscribe we're trying to get
the twenty thousand and then go down to
the parody and entire playlist and you
will see the interview that we did with
Eric Trump it's it's there Eric Trump
was
on the show
um here's his brother and Don Jr though
talking about whining about Hunter Biden
and projecting how he him and his family
are probably laundering money
um for documents that were sold to Saudi
Arabian money given to Jared Kushner
possibly I don't know I'm just saying
let's listen this is not a kickback
folks obviously it's not the 10 for the
big guy it's not another form of fraud
uh that Joe is family because you know
clearly they're they're good uh I'm sure
this is as legit as all of other Hunter
of all of hunters other dealings like
the artwork for half a million dollars
totally legit guys there's nothing to
see here right now if we had real
journalists The Logical next question
they should be asking Joe Biden is have
you ever collected rent from your son he
he really left the jubate in behind it
because he didn't say it like that he
said Joe he just said Joe Joe now here's
here I do want to bring this up okay I
will say in the art world
it is the art world is is incredibly
[ __ ] up okay uh there are there are
reports of money laundering because
here's the thing the free market doesn't
decide the price of art it's basically
wealthy you know Millions well they're
hiding they're hiding their money is
what they're doing inside so yeah
there's a whole there's a whole thing
money laundering scheme that happens not
saying that's happened with Hunter I'm
just saying that the art World itself
when you get pissed off about half a
million dollars in terms of something
getting purchased
that's not a Hunter Pro that's not a
hunter Biden problem that's an art
problem and how art private art is
bought and sold basically what happens
is you can have a nobody in a private
Gallery owner or a private owner buys a
piece of artwork says you know what I
love this so much it's a million dollars
and a lot of the time you'll have people
that will artificially inflate the price
and say oh it's 250 well I'll buy it for
300 and it's all right because they're
because they're trading money yeah
they're trading money right and it's
like so at the end of the day this is an
art world problem because it's just
private private owners and private
galleries rich people saying that's
worth this much money and then as a
result then you say oh well now the work
that comes out of this artist is now
we're setting a benchmark to say this is
the rough value if not it you know going
to increase over time
is worth you know and we're definitely
not saying art isn't worth money yeah
yeah but but
a lot of it is determined wealthy rich
people in our world and it is a world
problem not just our country it's a
world problem that's how they trade well
throughout the world and believe it or
not wealthy people just like they do
everything else they take advantage of
anything and any circumstance like art
being worth a lot of money real art real
value of art rare valuable art being
worth a lot of money they take advantage
of it by you know passing around and
redistributing the wealth to them itself
it's like uh Billy Zane in Titanic when
they're like oh this the drawing that
Leonardo DiCaprio Jack made about rose
right he was like oh it's gonna be worth
so much more now that he's dead right
you could just you could assign a value
and a price to something it's completely
arbitrary it's objective I think art is
[ __ ] and I'm a designer I think the
whole game is a [ __ ] Racket and
anyway but well here explains about
pricing he shouldn't be complaining
about Hunter he should be playing it
with the private the actual Art Market
itself but he goes on to talk about a
money laundering scheme that his family
has known to be participating and they
actually just got [ __ ] 17 counts his
company that he works for six one
million not enough not enough but that
was the max that he that the judge could
by paying for apartments for people at
the organization and their families was
part of the tax scheme to avoid taxes by
giving them income that way and here he
is I mean it is watch this but listen to
how he says Joe Biden he changed it see
here right now if we had real
journalists The Logical next question
they should be asking Joe Biden is have
you ever collected rent from your son
Hunter and if so how much did you
collect of course no journalist will
actually ask that question right which
proves they're not in fact journalists
but guys we've known this for a long
period of time but if it's not a way to
launder money or kick it back to Joe you
know again this could be the 10 for the
big guy who the hell is right just
Scrub by Hunter way over paying in rent
did a hunter and his Shady cohorts from
China Ukraine Russia did they have
access to the classified documents that
were stashed there I mean that would be
another logical question if we actually
had media okay so what and what Donald
Trump Jr is saying is look we did this
thing we totally let anyone see my dad
let totally let anyone see including
Kyle Rittenhouse when they came to
Lauren bobert see these documents
because he thought they were cool and
and we know he thought they were cool by
post today which I'm going to show here
in a minute
but he also is giving away the game when
they he's like look we were our company
that I helped run that we were just fine
1.61 million dollars were [ __ ] were
charged and convicted and sentenced for
that [ __ ] amount of money because
what we did was a money laundering
scheme to defraud the state of New York
for taxes so that way we could give
apartment and rent and I cannot believe
that because we did that that they're
not asking if they did that this is so
[ __ ] ridiculous that the media that
the media would ask anyone questions
just because the Trump family has
participated in money laundering and tax
fraud schemes with rented apartments
that you have to ask everyone that I
mean you would have to ask George Santos
because definitely he's tried to do that
but but you also but you also uh have to
remember that it's not like it's every
well okay we'll say this uh
Ivanka is smart she just stays out of
all of it uh she doesn't say [ __ ] uh but
when it comes to Eric and Don Jr and
Trump himself it's like the men of the
Trump family are the dumbest ones of all
okay because they go out and they say
these things you've got Trump who then
complains about the documents and Joe
Biden and the documents there and Jack
Smith there and blah blah blah blah all
this wickety-walkity well this this is
this is his rant um from this morning
that we're gonna show about confidential
empty confidential folders which he's
totally doing the same thing these
people was just doing these people
are our ego
like full of ego just [ __ ] full of
narcissism and [ __ ] sociopaths and it
always has to be about them they always
need the attention and the attention
isn't on them then they have to redirect
it and Trump he [ __ ] uses his Echo
Chamber Of Truth social to post it all
the [ __ ] time and say look at me look
at me look at me tippity type attack
typing because he complains about Joe
Biden about documents what he's saying
he's like oh no no no wait can we get a
Gabe Sanchez video of the tiny hands on
a keyboard going type typy typy yeah I
just I just want like a three four
second clip of the tiny ends with with
the uh with an audio over typey typey
typey typey typey
I beat type of typey
oh my god oh my god well here's here's
the uh
here's the shitty diaper post from uh
the Q the Cheeto dust q and honor
Grandpa poopy pants himself this morning
why does he start with page one what the
[ __ ] is that
he's been doing that a lot lately why
yeah I know I've noticed that we haven't
we haven't shown one of his uh his posts
in a while because but he's been just
all the same [ __ ] but this one's this
one's different sound more legitimate or
or he's like you know what this sounds
smarter like it sounds smarter I think
what he's doing here is he's like okay
look all these other people like Jack
Smith who [ __ ] hates my guts and Joe
Biden they have been finding pages and
pages and pages of documents and they
say they've got tons of pages of
documents again oh I see he's having
pages of documents what I think this is
you know what I think this is what I
think this is his version of the two
defiles as he calls them
I think he's true because they do like
Twitter files 23 and yeah
Twitter files 35. yeah they're talking
about [ __ ] Pfizer in connection with
oh my God Twitter
ah God damn it
anyways anyways so let's let's read this
um because this one is significant this
posterior significant here's why folks
is because he is he's saying something
new in this post yeah and again he's
giving away his own game here and the
reason why he has what he has right
because it's always projection it's
always confession yeah so he he he does
the typey typey here he says page one
the fake news media and crooked
Democrats that's been proven oh my God
oh my God that the projection there is
just [ __ ] just dripping just in that
first half statement the Crooked
Democrats that's been proven oh my God
uh he goes on keeps saying I had a quote
large number of documents in order he
used quotes right there I mean you know
in the context of his little delusion
yeah I guess that's the closest way here
they're not saying I had a quote-unquote
large they just said I had a large
number of documents like when when you
say quote-unquote large documents let's
keep in mind that they found over 300
plus
documents folders yeah folders folders
yeah and there's thousands of pages of
documents yeah uh this being uh only
page one of this rant by the way
speaking of pages I mean he goes on to
say large number of documents in order
to make the Biden classified docs look
less significant okay folks here's the
thing
here's the thing Joe Biden Joe Biden and
his attorneys did not find any documents
until the Penn Biden Center wanted their
office space and the storage cleaned out
that he was using and he hired attorneys
to go over and take that stuff out of
that storage and that's when they found
him on like November 2nd right and they
were turned over immediately you know
what I'll say
I do because there was that talk of like
oh we found five more documents and then
we found and it turns out they're the
same [ __ ] five documents because what
was the story here over the last weekend
they're like they found five more
documents it turns out the five
documents for the same five documents
they found earlier in the week so there
wasn't additional five documents it was
that the lawyers are like we found five
documents and then the FBI is like hey
we found five documents so it's they're
double counting it's the same five
documents regardless it's here what I
will say is when it comes to handling
the situation
they definitely haven't done it in the
best way but I'm also going to say again
like we've said on the show this is an
apple to Orange situation
Joe Biden did not hide lie steal and you
try to cover up it's not evidence of a
cover-up right and they won't sign
documents to say that this actually is
all of it there's no evidence that he
sold it to Saudi Arabia either is there
I don't think there is yet I don't know
maybe someone else did but there's a big
difference between the two of them right
well obviously I mean there's huge
differences between [ __ ] the Cheeto
dust q and honor and someone who
actually wants to work to be president
um not just Joe Biden but anyone who
would just get up in the morning put
their [ __ ] shoes on and do their job
not this schlub he goes on to say in
this post and this is this is the
important part here this last part where
he's admitting something he he and he
doesn't even know he's a meeting he's
trying to cover it up with this story he
said when I was in the Oval Office which
is
a huge stain on our nation
or elsewhere
what the [ __ ] or elsewhere and papers
quote were distributed by groups of
people and me
they would often be in a striped paper
folder with classified or confidential
or another word on them okay so what
he's saying is what most people know is
that a [ __ ] a piece of classified
information is in a folder Gabe Sanchez
it's a closable folder so you can close
it you know what I mean so you can't
actually that's not folders that's how
folder folders work yep and then on the
folder it has writing on it to identify
what kind of is maybe in the folder
right these are things these are things
that folder a non-folder people need to
know so then he goes on to say this is
this is [ __ ] where the confession
comes
when the session was over they would
collect the papers but not the folders
and I saved hundreds of them
this is not this is all [ __ ] this is
all [ __ ] all this is the I have a
very hard time believing I heard an
intelligence Community would say oh you
know what [ __ ] the folders We Don't Need
context for what these files are you
know what who needs who needs folders
yeah who needs let's just throw them on
your [ __ ] tacky carpet yeah we'll
store them there not in folders this
guy's a Bonet here's the next one okay
let's just keep in mind that Jack Smith
is just sitting back and he's like yeah
keep typing type it tap it please tell
me tell me all the places I should look
is basically he's like I'm just gonna
follow here for a real-time play-by-play
of how you broke the law and tried to
lie about covering up for breaking the
law this is so [ __ ] stupid why again
we are seriously at the at the
intersection of WrestleMania in real
life and this is reality TVs TV
trumpster fire in real time here this
this morning okay this is page two he
types page two now anyone who actually
makes post knows that you can just do
one slash uh two or two slash it's kind
of sound It's gotta sound important you
gotta know that this is a page look at
this page on the interwebs
did he use does he use his his Sharpie
when he's writing these Pages
he might write them out first he goes oh
yeah that's a good way to capitalize
that right with the sharpie yeah okay so
here's what he says because it get oh it
gets better folks because we're gonna
get to the gazpacho police he gets it
wrong he he doesn't know that it's
gazpacho now
um
those cold soupy [ __ ] yes
um page two he says remember
these were just ordinary inexpensive
folders with various words printed on
them like classified oh God oh my God
these are just ordinary inexpensive
folders they were nothing they were
nothing Gabe Sanchez it's almost like
they had no value or no significance at
all yeah it's almost like a do not share
uh uh oh for you know for POTUS Eyes
Only uh confidential classified top
secret you know what they're just words
guys and if you rearrange the letters
they spell different words and that's
called an anagram
listen if anyone is confused out there
the difference between the Trump
documents case and the Biden's document
case this guy doesn't even know the
seriousness of the folders of the [ __ ]
that he was looking at folders from
Office Depot with various words on there
right I don't know what they said
because I can't read so I just took the
paper and the folders oh it's going to
get better here but the difference is
Joe Biden is soon at Jim Eden as soon as
they found the documents the FBI came to
get them immediately it didn't matter
what [ __ ] inexpensive folder they
were in or if it was on the floor in a
box or locked or whatever they it's
found them they immediately called the
proper authorities to come get them
immediately this guy is making bones
because here's my guess Gabe Sanchez is
his attorneys know they've already had
conferences with Jack Smith and the
special counsel and their indication his
attorneys are like they're they're going
to get you on these empty folders what
the [ __ ] were in those folders that's
that's what this is right um but it gets
hilarious it gets even more mockable and
funny because right after he's [ __ ]
doesn't understand the significance of
classified folders Jesus Christ he goes
on to say but they were cool quotes
keepsakes
perhaps the gazpacho and he says gestapo
and you know gazpacho you spit you took
some of these empty folders when they
raided Mar-A-Lago and counted them as
documents which they are not that's not
what they did that's not even close
that's not even close
he went to court Gabe Sanchez this guy
went to court to get the inventory on
record in public record out of court
unsealed and they unsealed it and they
showed in the report what how many
documents how many there were how many
empty folders there was an inventory
done this is so stupid they're not they
didn't count the empty folders documents
they counted them as empty folders on
the inventory that's why he's terrified
here he's terrified because he knows
Jack Smith knows heed or destroyed the
documents or he [ __ ] sold them one or
the other one or the other he didn't
[ __ ] destroyed him or he [ __ ]
stole him that's that's what he's doing
here now I I never knew really
honestly when we got the indication that
that there were empty folders in that
inventory my first thought was well this
[ __ ] bonehead was just getting [ __ ]
out and showing people and just stuffing
them back into any old folder yeah he
didn't give a [ __ ] and that's how we had
you know dozens of empty folders but my
now I believe based on his [ __ ] post
here this guy [ __ ] destroyed or sold
our top secret dot like physically
destroyed them or sold them because why
would you say oh guys I didn't take the
files I just took the folders like
that's no the only one who gives a [ __ ]
who gives a [ __ ] if they're counting
them as documents or not really honestly
if that's the truth if they are counted
which they're not we've seen the
inventory we literally the evidence
based on the unsealed evidence from the
search news man right yeah but the idea
that he's like guys guys why is everyone
freaking out okay I just took some
folders and when they come they took
they they collect okay they collect the
papers inside them but I just took the
folders I have a hard time believing
that if Trump was in a [ __ ] skiff and
he had to review documents God damn I
have to think about the idea that Trump
had to review just just the sake of our
own Safety and Security in our country
but the fact that he was in a skiff and
he opens a folder he goes hmm hmm
okay and they go okay you know we've
discussed we've we've briefly take that
folder and they go we'll take that back
and he goes no mine and they go no sir
we we need to take a dessert no I keep
the folder and and he's fighting with
him and he's like oh we should well we
should get John Walsh on this we should
get John Walsh on this we should
definitely give me my folder give me my
folder okay the idea that he would do
that and the idea that he would just go
in here and be like guys look I just had
folders okay so what of course when you
show up to [ __ ]
search his house legally search his
house
uh he goes they're just folders I didn't
I didn't do anything bad yeah it's
probably because you [ __ ] get you hid
those you buried him and ivana's uh uh
[ __ ] coffin or you sold them I
destroyed them they're somewhere or not
somewhere but they were in the folders
at some point okay so he goes on to say
because this gets it this gets even more
deranged this gets even mortar range
because now now he's trying to make sure
that that they don't prosecute him if
they don't prosecute Joe
because he's really scared here that
these two cases are different because he
knows his intent and what he did because
his lawyers are like it doesn't look so
good yeah dude you're [ __ ] like look
man we're not the smartest lawyers but
we know that this is not this is not
good so he says he says here
he typey typeys it's also possible that
Trump hating Marxist thugs I don't know
who they are I don't know who these I
don't know do you consider yourself a
trump-hating Marxist Thug I kind of
think that would be a good title on my
business card I think honestly I'm a you
know what I am I am I'm a I'm a Marxist
I'm a trump-hating mark sick no you know
what I'm I'm uh I'm a Campbell's Soup
throwing yeah Trump hating yeah Mark six
Marxist Thug Oh okay that's so you get
okay
current position that is what it is so
he says Trump hating Marxist thugs in
charge will quote plant documents while
they're in possession of materials folks
this is why I keep telling you stop
talking about the Secret Service
planning documents it's going to bite
you in the ass that's gonna it already
is that's gonna be a stupid [ __ ]
thing if you're a liberal and you're and
you're and you want Donald Trump to pay
for his crimes stop talking about how
Secret Service Plan documents you're
[ __ ] playing into his hands because
he's doing it right here now he goes on
to say as president
and based on presidential record act and
Sox case he's talking about the Bill
Clinton Sox oh my God
he says I did nothing wrong Joe did he's
he's totally giving away the game that
Joe Biden's case is gonna in six months
we're gonna get a special counsel report
my guess is Gabe Sanchez probably five
or six months yeah Special counsel
report we're gonna find out exactly what
happened but the documents the White
House is going to be totally transparent
making sure that that special counsel
review is released to the public so the
public knows everything
and they're probably not going to
comment past that special accounts for
review that'll be the end of it that'll
be the end with Merrick Garland that'll
be the end with the Biden Administration
that'll be it that'll be all we hit we
see it and they'll be like yep there it
is you can read it you go go look at
that I will refer you to the special
counsel's evidence
and within six months Donald Trump is
going to have federal charges against
him for those [ __ ] empty folders
whatever he did whatever he did around
those empty folders they're going to be
federal indictments around those empty
folders and he did break the
presidential uh uh Records act because
of those empty folders that because he's
telling us he's saying it right here in
his fraud social post yeah and I I just
I I can't express how many times I mean
with the the the uh 2016 Russian
collusion no obstruction no collusions
are coming in and
causing this issue there was obstruction
there was collusion there was
obstruction there was collusion so he
was telling you exactly the crimes that
he committed during that time period so
uh Kyle Chaney uh by the way had those
um on his uh accounts regretted here but
I wanted to read those and spend some
time on those because that is most the
time he's just saying the same it's the
same [ __ ] different diaper Dave Sanchez
most of the time at this post but that
one was significant that one was
significant
uh let's see what other news do we have
here uh today uh oh oh just wanted to
point this out it is very true yeah he
does he always tells on himself yeah he
can't help it he's got to talk about
himself he's got to make himself the
[ __ ] Focus the attention seeking
Spotlight humping Donald Trump spray tan
bitching
documents stealing
truth social ranting
uh air quote not getting right then yeah
listen Gabe Sanchez you do you have a
younger sibling right
okay I have a younger sibling too yeah
this is the same thing when they would
break something
and they would be like oh the dog did it
right yeah um never tried that excuse
but always you know I give props to
people who try my my brother
um self-taught him uh golf he likes golf
taught himself how to golf and I did it
in the yard we had a big huge field we
lived on a farm so there's a big
Behavior so he would hit golf balls out
into the Hayfield and then he'd go get
him anyways he would practice his golf
swing in the house you know not like
slowly like slow-mo just like full full
[ __ ] Force right 100 we're not
slowing this down we lived in a
farmhouse and it was old it was built in
1941 and it had the original white
fixture in the living room this thing
was ugly as [ __ ] but it was like an
antique and it worked so we didn't take
it down right yeah it was just my dad is
Frugal like he could pick a [ __ ] dime
off the floor with his butt cheeks type
Frugal nice yeah now that this this this
white fixture in the living room it's a
glass light fixture
a lot of people might like this light
fixture today
but my mom came home one day and the
[ __ ] light fixture was broke in half
and some of it was laying on the living
room floor now one would think one would
think you could do a little bit of math
and understand probably what happened
would be that someone might have
possibly been swinging a golf club yeah
yeah so my mom asked him about it and
his response was oh the dog did it
yeah
the dog the dog was kind of old at the
time I've seen some crazy videos where
they jump on the rope and then they say
yeah but have you ever have you ever
watched the dog golf before this is
amazing that it is pretty pretty cool
but here's the thing
my brother was very young when this
happened he was very young and of course
you know you don't want to get in
trouble because you broke something
that's a [ __ ] antique and it's
hanging in the living room like and
there was another one there was an
identical one in the dining room right
these light pictures were [ __ ] ugly
but at the time in 1941
these light fixtures were [ __ ]
expensive yeah I mean they were Primo
light fixtures back in 1941 so that's
why we kept them up because they were
they were they [ __ ] worked number one
and if it doesn't if it ain't broke
don't fix it type [ __ ] but but he broke
it with this golf club and he blamed on
the dog but that's exactly what's
happening here and and what I'm saying
is he's a [ __ ] child he's a child who
can't take responsibility and
accountability so he just makes up
whatever he wants to make up and he
basically tells on himself by doing it
right yeah it is it every [ __ ] time
they do this every [ __ ] time it's all
web of wise
um speaking of Web of Lies let's go back
to Santos for a second this is where it
just keeps unraveling so um I love how
they frame this guy up as former friend
of George Santa is he that is he the
four is he the one that he stole the
scarf from I don't [ __ ] know that I
didn't I mean
there's the former roommate yeah and
then there's I guess the former friend I
forget if they're both the same but one
of them the one that he went to the stop
the steel rally that wasn't even his
scarf he stole that scarf from his
roommate the video we watched the other
day he stole that scarf yeah
he is a typical Republican this [ __ ]
guy oh my God okay so um Anderson Cooper
yeah I'll say I'll just say this if
you're gonna steal something don't go on
TV and show it off okay
Trump oh okay dear dear dear just cool
keepsakes they're just they're just
they're just ordinary ordinary full
oh my God okay here's George Santos's
friend I wonder if he knows anything
about uh ordinary folders too but let's
listen how long did you actually live
together okay we were only uh roommates
for a few months and I also knew him as
uh Anthony zabrovski
why did he say he had two names then
so he so he's obviously he may or may
have a guy that he stole the scarf from
oh is this the scarf Guy this is the
yeah his former or now that are now the
non-scarf guy because he got a sweater
it clearly looks like he's got a sweater
over his shoulder but uh yeah the scarf
is
it was his yeah okay well let's let's
keep listening why George Santos changed
his name because I think it's important
in this clip
well he he used the brovsky for his uh
friends of pets United because
um
uh is GoFundMe and so that that is the
GoFundMe that he used to steal the three
thousand dollars from the veteran who
was uh apparently homeless at the time
um he had a service dog and the service
dog needed a surgery
um and he relied on the service dog so
the vet I guess or someone at the vet
connected Santos or zabrodsky I think
that's what they said his name he used
and he's going to tell you why he used
his name and it's oh boy it's Jewish oh
my lord it's [ __ ] crazy here I'm
telling you that's what's gonna happen
here is he he he totally leans into and
and
absolutely mocks uh and uses
anti-Semitism here to anyways the point
is
is that this is the same charity that he
used to fleece the three thousand
dollars from the veteran about his
service dog surgery that the dog never
received Santo's got the money but he
never the dog never received the surgeon
I think the dog died as a result but
let's listen to why he uses that name
it's [ __ ] crazy and he would say oh
well you know the Jews will give more if
you're a Jew and so that's the name he
used for his gofundme's and okay so this
is
Gabe Sanchez this is where I believe
that that George Santos remember uh a
couple weeks ago this is one of the
first things we found out about him that
he wasn't Jewish he he was saying he was
telling his campaign staff that I'm
Jewish yeah right because in the
interview he uses because he uses a
Jewish name right right make him but the
idea of Jewish yeah what he said in an
interview he's like I've always been up
front I've always said I've I've
Catholic and this and that but I'm
Jewish like ish and it's like we're
really gonna make we're really gonna
make a joke about this like we're okay
all right sounds good yeah keep doubling
down let's see how this goes it would be
like me taking a Hispanic last name and
be like yeah I'm Mexican like what makes
you well I just decided that that would
be my last name yeah this is you know
what I I woke up this morning I just
felt a little spicy right I don't know a
little right it's Tuesday you know I
want to have a different name today
they're dude I'm telling you man this is
this this is ever Republican though this
is every [ __ ] one of them and I know
I know Republicans don't change their
names and all that [ __ ]
um but they definitely do [ __ ] like this
because they believe what he just said
the anti-Semitism is is that Jews will
give more money if they know they're
giving it to to Jewish people right
that's literally what he that's that was
the thought process is that oh well
they'll they'll they'll think I'm Jewish
so they'll give me the Jews and also
more money yeah and not only that but
the idea that he's like oh Jewish people
have money right and they're rich right
and they're mostly Frugal with other
people who aren't Jewish right it's
anti-Semitism 101 but um uh let's see
how Anderson Cooper responds because he
looks really confused does Anderson look
really confused here
how old is Anderson Cooper by the way I
don't want you this [ __ ] show I don't
know that's a good uh let's see I mean
the dudes had white hair for like 30
years yeah I mean obviously Anderson
Cooper comes from money so well right
right uh Anderson Cooper is 55 years old
he he he's 55 he's been he's been white
for like third since he was 25 then I
know let's just say like the constant
white hair and probably a good skin care
routine right
so it kind of hides the wrinkles right
well I'll tell you I he looks Forever
Young other than the hair I don't think
he looks 55 to be quite honest no no not
at all I mean he died and good on
Anderson he doesn't dye his hair he just
lets it Go all Natty there yeah um you
know Daddy light you know right so Natty
white yeah that's why Natty white
because it's white hair oh yes yes yes
yes yes and he's a pasty white guy Okay
let's listen to what Anderson because he
looks really confused let's see what he
says what was he having gofundme's for
back then
uh his he had a bad charity friends of
pets United uh it was supposedly to
um help out with you know sick animals
and things like that there's actually
um just an article released from
um uh one of my reporters uh who's been
interviewing me a lot uh Jacqueline
sweet about how he conned a uh homeless
military vet out of three thousand
dollars for his uh service dog now Gabe
Sanchez the way that this guy is smiling
when he's telling this story
it almost feels like to me that George
Santos or whatever the [ __ ] his name is
um actually bragged about stealing this
money to people like not only did he
griffed it but he he bragged about it it
feels yeah
I mean you know I'm sure I'm sure he I'm
sure the roommate was like how'd you pay
the rent this month
let me tell you let me tell you what
story you gotta get on this GoFundMe
yeah I saw this this houseless veteran
and I scammed him out of this money that
I fundraised for him and his dog and the
guy's like and I used a Jewish name to
do it yeah yeah and he's like and I and
I changed my name to Anthony zabrovski
because Jewish people give money and
actually it turns out they gave me more
money and he's like whoa wait a minute
and the dog died
and he's like that's really [ __ ] up
man he goes yeah I know and he says I'm
gonna run for Congress and it's a shame
because I can make more money yeah
scamming veterans he's like yeah I know
and I'm gonna do it again and he does it
with you know yeah he's like I'm taking
money from uh what his his relative is
uh
is a Russian is is somehow connected to
Russia dude this is a whole I I keep
getting distracted out I've been meaning
to do what was that but then the problem
is that all of this [ __ ] keeps coming
out and I'm like maybe I should just
wait like a week or something because
these stories are crazy it's everywhere
and they're more ridiculous it's not
just the money it's this God they're
like the schemes you go around because
obviously you know we should mock them
and if we really want to mock them then
let's you know let's get the let's get
the good stories out like changing your
name to a Jewish name so that people
give you money and because you think
because you believe in your own deluded
little [ __ ] fake reality a party in a
party that is so pro-veteran and
pro-military you're gonna scam I can't
wait to hear what Republicans say about
that one
why why do
you'll be waiting a long time yeah and
he sits on a committee with a bunch of
other people just like you're going to
be waiting a long time for any
Republican to comment on Pena and the
domestics some have and they're like we
we don't support this type of behavior
it's like yeah now they was caught right
right right oh you don't we are all the
messages we're having shootings not that
you knew that they're politically
motivated but if you're starting to
track down and say oh they're all
Democrats why why do all these these
Republicans these America First Nazis
why are they all really horrible so he
was funded by a cousin of a Russian yeah
yeah why why are all these people just
the worst Batman villains ever oh
there's a yes
this is this is how bad they are it's
just terrible
typically when you meet like a bond
villain or like a basketball or
something they have there's always a
monologue they go on a diet tribe about
some [ __ ] and how they were hurt and
they were triggered by something so then
they decided to take it out in the world
and they decided to hold something
Ransom and say I want this one million
dollars right that's one of that's one
of the best parodies and satires a bond
and and Batman villains is the Austin
Power movie right but then they are even
worse
they are a 99 cent discount DVD in the
[ __ ] please take this from our store
bin at a Dollar Tree
that is the type of like shitty movie
where they have a villain and they're
like so is there any plots of this movie
no plot whatsoever just a ton of
dialogue and random [ __ ] and this guy
going on a diatribe and telling the you
know the the antagonist telling the the
protagonists like what they're gonna do
and the in the plans they have and all
this [ __ ] [ __ ]
and then you find out that the whole
movie was just this [ __ ] monologue
diatribe that the villain went on and
they didn't actually go through and
actually follow uh follow with the the
crime or the the plan that they had
that's that's that is that is the when I
think of them I'm like this is a shitty
Bond villain in a discount bin DVD VHS
got you know first like they'll pay you
99 cents to take the [ __ ]
they're like please please
[ __ ] to just take this off our hands
like just we'll just say it was stolen
just stay we'll turn a blind eye right
right free yeah
um speaking of bond villains and crime
and projection this is a story we were
following uh I don't know if you heard
this but Andrew Tate's in a lot of
trouble for human trafficking and the
reason why they've how they found him is
because
he instigated a a beef on Twitter with
Greta Thunder
and she she uh Pizza boxed his ass now
yeah
um that's why we recycle Tony right well
that is true Save the Planet save your
own ass from prosecution Okay so
Andrew the Andrew Tate stands out there
are [ __ ] big mad this morning about
her getting arrested now I don't know
exactly where this happened I don't know
exactly okay it was in Germany I guess
she was at a protest okay she's
protesting a coal mine I I really
honestly
um she's doing great work around the
world and I don't pay too much attention
only to Pizza Box pizza box post but I
do pay attention when the Andrew Tate
stands get hugely mad when they think
her arrest was staged and I'm not gonna
play the audio because it's not really
significant here yeah um but these are
the authorities uh taking her into
custody and they that they're saying
that this is stage the the Andrew Tate's
in they're really pissed off that she
put him in a Romanian prison and
apparently they just uh update is on the
Andrew Tate thing I I guess they detain
him for like 180 more days they extended
it or some [ __ ] yeah so so you're like
oh 30 day days and they're like no this
is uh real quick he tried to fight it
and they're like no no you're gonna
remain stay here for the remainder and
then they came out and they're like oh
yeah and you get 180. right so here here
is a video of uh again uh Greta being uh
detained by the authorities and I think
at one point they pick her up and carry
her across the water puddle right um so
she doesn't have to walk through it
that's one of the pictures that's going
around the internet but here's the thing
about this video is there this clown
world I don't know who the [ __ ] this
account is we have our suspicions and
we're gonna try to track this down and
let the audience know if we can track
this down who this clown world is but we
have our suspicions
um and Gabe really has a suspicion here
and uh maybe we'll maybe we'll get to
the bottom of it but um this clown World
um account which keeps popping up on my
[ __ ] timeline
um do I follow him is that why nope see
that I don't follow them and they
[ __ ] like I said my time I've got
people I've got I've got idiots that I
blocked that show up on my feed right
and I was like oh that you blocked their
their emails and they shoved my feed so
then I go and I'm like I'm pretty sure I
blocked this person and I go in and it
shows yeah you're blocked or this person
is blocked I'm like what the [ __ ] why is
this well
see the thing is is um they're really
trying to propagate
um your timeline they're really trying
to propagate the lobby and this clown
world is a great way to to um to
propagate it because they post a lot of
non-political videos this clown world
because they've showed up several times
in my feed but they showed up in my feed
this morning and it says totally not
staged hahaha like they're burning her
or something right yeah they're totally
mad they're totally mad about about
Greta staging of video Gabe Sanchez as
if the arch enemy of Greta who is the
recent Arch Enemy besides climate change
yeah
um Andrew Tate doesn't stage everything
like all of it he staged the Tweet where
he he told her about the 33 cars which
he doesn't own 33 and he definitely he
didn't own any now they sold them all oh
yeah apparently and and he and he he
staged the pizza box thing the video at
the beach box which led them partially
to go away arrest him
um they're mad that she's staging a
video this is [ __ ] just I I just
Internet it's just funny because there's
no idea stuff that they're pissed off
that he went to jail
and then he's in prison for 180 days oh
he's going to prison properly
summers are gonna [ __ ] lock him away
I think 15 or 20 years is is what people
suspect they're gonna give him anyway
he's not he's not gonna do so well he'll
be someone's [ __ ] in prison I'm sure uh
and what's gonna happen maybe maybe if
Greta goes to prison for climate change
maybe he'll be her [ __ ] yeah yeah she's
like look I'll be leaning on you if you
[ __ ] give me your your food
but uh but they're so pissed off that
she got arrested for this which which is
protesting a coal mine right because
again she's an environmentalist and she
that's within her wheelhouse and just
like within his wheelhouse it's sex
trafficking so right you know what he
went to prison he's gonna go to [ __ ]
jail in long time long long time and uh
so is she so is she and for the causes
that they care about I bet and I bet the
thing that pisses off these these Andrew
taint stands the most is the fact that
they're still paying into Hustler's
University and they're not getting any
content what's hilarious about these
Andrew taint as you call them uh stands
um you go to any Andrew Tate [ __ ]
post and you go to the comments and it
is full I mean just packed with eight
dollar checks Eight dollar checks
everywhere the same people who defend
Andrew taint defending on musk I don't
know if there's a Venn diagram that you
could come up with but I'm sure it's
just a [ __ ] Circle yes
[Music]
Elon Elon Andrew Elon Andrew do you
think Twitter files
do you think do you think there's
there's like uh um AI porn out there of
Andrew Tate and and Elon and I'm sure
somebody and if somebody's listening out
here and they have their own little uh
AI you know you could probably you well
you could be fake you could fake a
couple people and you could probably
open up a website and charge these guys
at least eight dollars they'll pay eight
dollars at least yeah eight dollars
you agreed to it that's the terms of
service
oh my God what a show today
on a Wednesday January 18th I'm sure
there'll be more news tomorrow and we
will be back regardless of the news
whatever it is you know we will deliver
it here to you at the Tony Michaels
podcast Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central on YouTube Twitter
and twitch every single weekday don't
forget to subscribe to the YouTube
channel do US that favor and also do us
this favor share it with three of your
friends and get them to share three
times we're trying to get to twenty
thousand and if everyone shares and gets
three people we'll be at like 50 before
you know it that's just that's just the
numbers game baby we're gonna kill 20
000 because you're the best audience in
the world don't forget to give love to
the moderators in the chat because
you're the best audience and they're the
best moderators in the entire world
Gabe Sanchez
I know Wednesday's not over so the news
is not over there's even a story we
didn't even get to another story that is
about TSA finding oh yes
in the passenger's luggage at the Texas
maybe maybe we'll get to it tomorrow
probably not because there'll be a ton
of Republican [ __ ] in the meantime
because these people are bonehead speak
on that go follow us on Twitter at Tony
Michaels pod you can vote for bone net
of the week there tomorrow after the
show in the evening and also you can
vote on the YouTube channel so again
don't forget we're pushing for twenty
thousand two years of Tony 20 000
subscribe to the YouTube channel until
tomorrow same time same place
Surf's Up [ __ ] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's mewborn headass Beacon